voilà le sel et le véhicule de
déneigement du 14 novembre au 13 mars
2017 le département mobilise des
effectifs supplémentaires pour assurer
aux usagers des conditions de
circulation fluide on renforce
l'astreinte c'est à dire qu'en fait on
va voir 37 agents qui sont d'astreinte
24 heures sur 24 pour éventuellement
intervenir ou sur sur les routes des
yvelines en cas de phénomènes qui
pourraient être potentiellement bisang
stockés dans différents entrepôts ce
sont au total trois mille huit cent
cinquante tonnes de sel qui sont
accessibles aux agents des montagnes
prête à être dispersés pour éviter tout
accident de la route
les interventions restent cependant
rares si je prends l'exemple de l'an
dernier n'est sorti je crois 144 fois et
c'était 5 fois seulement curatif donc ça
veut dire que ça explose 135 x en
préventif le bon état des 1400 km de
routes départementales ne dépend pas
seulement de la réactivité des agents
publics mais aussi du bon sens des
usagers
soyons vigilants ayant les bons réflexes
si on me dit que les conditions risquent
d'être mauvaise
eh bien je me renseigne bien avant de
tenter quoi que ce soit parce que si
vous vous retrouvez sur une route dans
laquelle vous ne pouvaient plus circuler
parce que les conditions sont
impraticables
eh bien vous créer des désordres vous
créez les embouteillages voir des
accrochages et surtout les saleuses ne
peuvent plus passer pour éviter les
embouteillages veillez donc à ne pas
vous engager sur les routes si les
chutes de neige sont trop importantes et
à ne pas gêner l'action des sableuses